dr fauci do you still
support funding of the nih funding of
the lab in wuhan
the nih has not ever and does not now
fund gain of function research
in the wuhan institute we have not
funded
gain of function research on this i will
repeat again
the nih and niaid
categorically has not funded gain of
function
research yeah i mean i just wanted to
say we i
i don't know how many times i can say it
well maybe one more
how many times can he say it dr fatchi
being very careful with his words with
senator rand paul today
fauci says the nih and the nyad never
directly funded gain of function
research
at the institute the wuhan institute of
urology but like we said before that's
before that's true but it's also
misleading you see the nih headed by dr
fauci sent
3.7 million dollars to a non-profit
called
echo health alliance which then turned
around and sent 600 000 from that grant
to the wuhan lab i hope you're following
that take your time play this back
dr factory's favorite sparring partner
joins us now senator rand paul
senator rand paul you felt it you feel
as though using some of the things i
just said
that dr fauci was being deceptive today
in what way
well i think it's incredibly important
that the audience know what gain of
function is
they take an animal virus that's benign
and does not infect humans
and they juice it up they make it a
super virus so it can infect
humans now ostensibly this is done to
study the virus but there's a danger if
that virus leaks that it could kill a
lot of people
so when i asked him about this research
we knew the answer
the answer is this that there's a famous
scientist in the wuhan lab
her name is dr she and she published a
paper a couple years ago
which has been reviewed by mit and says
that it's a gain of function
research but in the byline she has to
list the sponsors
she lists dr fauci and the niaid
as a sponsor of her research which
everybody acknowledges gain of function
research juicing up these super viruses
so
i don't know how he can get around this
he could argue oh it was an intermediary
group we gave it to ecohealth who gave
him the money
i think i can't imagine he's on national
television saying
that he didn't do this when the
peer-reviewed journal
has a byline that says the author this
bat woman this scientist from the wuhan
institute
that she acknowledges that the money
came from dr fauci and his institute
so this is a dangerous act okay let's
say it's science i want to stop the next
one so i got to see what happens
when we activate these viruses but other
people say it's too dangerous if this
gets out
it's going to be devastating somehow it
could have gotten
out is that what you're saying senator i
don't think we know for sure but yes
it could have gotten out and there are a
lot of people arguing that there are
several different
unusual aspects to the virus that make
it look like
it came from a lab and not from nature
they haven't found an
intermediate host they haven't found
anything between the bat the human
both sars and mers went to an
intermediate host like a ferret or a
civet
but the other thing that's peculiar
about this is that when we look at this
and we say
you know did it come directly the way
they're studying this in the lab they
studied the sars virus
this is the one like cove that came
around in 2004
but had a 15 mortality so they juiced up
this already deadly virus and made it
more ineffective into humans
in the lab they've admitted that they
did that but can you imagine
15 mortality covid19 has a 1
mortality that means instead of three
million people dying worldwide
if the one of the viruses that she
worked on with nih money
got out 45 million people could have
died
there are 11 labs like this in the u.s
that are studying animal viruses that
they're transforming
into deadly human viruses 11 labs like
this in the united states
so what is important for people to
understand is that
forgetting about dr faucina's future or
your political future this is about
understanding how this started
to stop the next virus if we don't
understand how this started
we're going to get slammed again and
we're going to be ill-equipped once
again
i don't understand the lack of curiosity
from dr fauci this is his business
why is that not his obsession rather
than being on 25 talk shows a day
if you want to be even more confounded
by this
they wanted to investigate what happened
over there
the person they investigated is the head
of eco health
so they invested they hired the person
to investigate whether there was a
problem at the lab
they hired the guy that gave them the
money so if something came out that said
this virus came from the lab
do you think the person that gave them
the money might have culpability
so they hired they hired the guy to do
the investigation
who has a conflict of interest here so
you start to wonder
all of these wagons are circling the
chinese communists aren't talking
we gave them the money i mean there's a
lot of potential problems here but once
again i'm not saying it did come from
the lab i don't know
but there's a lot of evidence that makes
me worried about this lab
and the fact that people are not being
honest the fact that dr fauci would lie
and say that he didn't give any money to
this lab now maybe his answer is like
you said he gave it to an intermediary
who gave it to them but if that's his
answer i would think that's a kind of a
curious way of saying it didn't happen
when it really did happen
and i got to leave it here four months
into the coronavirus emergency the
deputy director of the nih wrote an
email to echo health
and they said quote you were instructed
to cease providing any funds of the
wuhan institute
peter danzig is the chief scientist
there he quickly got 77 nobel prize
winners to sign a statement
saying not to deprive them of their
money what's the desperation to get
western money
into an area where we know the virus
came from
some way somehow but here's the other
interesting thing
if fauci's deputy is writing a note
saying that they're going to stop the
money
that implies that there was money
flowing to the wuhan institute
he says no money was flowing to the
wuhan institute well then why was it
stopped i mean none of this makes sense
none of it makes sense at all and i just
wonder
uh when a democrat and i hear senator
menendez and others are being mobilized
to understand that this
is national security and we've got to
find out it'll be the biggest liability
case in the history of man
and china would be at the forefront and
maybe some others uh senator rand paul
thanks for asking the tough questions
especially over the last year
and especially today as it has to do
with the science i know you got 20
million things to do
i appreciate you joining us tonight
thanks hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox you can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now